Carter page advised the Trump campaign
and was later monitored by the federal
government and treated him like a spy he
joins us tonight Carter thanks coming up
thanks for having me Tucker so just to
get this out of the way at the outset
did you help any of these indicted
Russians set up fake Facebook pages or
plan any of their sparsely attended
rallies for them the only facebook
shenanigans that were happening with
state-sponsored media was Radio Free
Europe they they published this fake
fake news from the dodgy dossier in
September 2016 and that was rebroadcast
'add
sponsored media outlet Radio Free Europe
which is sponsored by broadcasting Board
of Governors out of Washington so that's
the closest I ever had with any any sort
of you know government sponsored news
outlets oh no so you're an Annapolis
graduate you were a naval intelligence
officer for five years presumably that
mark she was a patriotic American did
you ever imagine that your government
would be spying on you at any point well
I mean I had some warnings about that
back in starting in the summer of 2016
and in just September and actually when
I sent my letter to director Comey on
September 25th 2016 I was you know I
immediately called this out as a
witch-hunt and so I had some advance
warning about that and I also warned him
about you know and I said instead of
allowing the staff of the FBI to focus
limited resources on real threats these
desperate and unfounded calls for my
investigation as a private citizen are a
true disgrace and unfortunately as we
saw this week down in Florida that that
prediction turned out to be absolutely
correct so instead of focusing on some
of these real threats out there you know
they were wasting a tremendous amount of
money at time and resources on this
complete witch hunt
and violating your civil liberties now
one of the reasons they were able to get
a FISA warrant to break into your life
and spy on you is because of the steel
dossier which we reread last week
because why not and in it I'd forgotten
there was the allegation that you
received a percentage of a Russian
company shares in that company
which would be worth about eleven
billion dollars and so I guess the
obvious question is did you ever get
eleven billion dollars from the Russians
for spying on the United States for
betraying your country I'm still waiting
for that Tucker and actually it's funny
the company that did end up acquiring
that those shares is Glencore and that
was founded by Mark rich who was
pardoned by you know in the last days of
the Clinton administration so they think
yes that's that's so so I mean I don't
want to get you know into a lot of
pathos here I don't even know you I've
never talked to you before tonight but
I've just been wondering as I watch you
again as an Annapolis graduate and a
former naval officer having your life
destroyed by the US government like what
do you do for money and how much does
this cost you and what does this done to
your life I keep thinking that Tucker
the last major intelligence failure by
the US intelligence community led to
deaths of thousands of US military
citizen Terry officers and soldiers and
airmen so to me this is a minor cost and
so I've just I'm just thankful that this
false intelligence that was put into the
bloodstream of the US government yeah
was not followed up on and you know
President Trump was able to call this
out for the complete lies that that and
misinformation that it was well I'm
sorry you never got the 11 billion in
blood money that Steele claims you did
Carter page thank you good to see if
Tucker you too